scores of british gas in free world
inspire committed catalyst i add
a fourth opportunity scores gulf
stream ns is free director in two
worlds
intense
exciting and rewarding
what they are seen links with the uk in
france
i am franco american is very
attached to  my multicultural identity
i was really lucky to spend my
higher education in the uk and
it changed my life it was a very strange
trainer and it still remains an
integral part of who i am
what i do describes the british
kanto dolls  is a killer do they feel
we are the british international agency
that creates it strengthens the links
between people botanic l1 different countries
including france here in france we
reach nearly one
million five hundred thousand people every year
through our activities linked in  the
bridge canso is not
the goal she can it is not political
is not exclusive and
is not just made up of the brits  years
who work for the risk in fact
we are really motivated cultural
inclusive and it is sure that we
work on the axes which are
continual educational dancing naked in
the opportunities
weaving the links much stronger
through our peoples and our histories
than we  share what is the british empire
we are about to enter france
so it's exciting we have
students arriving on our premises
and we have the opportunity to start with
our partners the various
activities that we have predicted for a long
time but also  we have the opportunity
because she has just arrived the first
british ambassador
manor rowling and she is taking her break
this week in this real
opportunity for us to work
together with the embassy and with
the ambassador on the axes which are
strong between france  and the United Kingdom on the
other hand I think that we are
starting to work on the
various major projects for example the
juice  de lime pic paris 2024 will arrive very
soon and so we have
contributed enormously to this opportunity between our
countries and the countries in europe would you
like to see fast i
would like bridge when alone
mark well the history of france and
the kingdom  united I think
Franco-British relations are
still very, very strong but we
can do more to be a beacon
in strengthening its ties
during these difficult times I think
we need a British ganso who
works on the educational level
cult using in my
large part of the events that happen
for example the juice of the epic paris 24 and
speaks a peak through the summits and
the other washington events in
digital and physically world the brick
in the wall industry
the digital world is  become a part
of us
but we can't just do everything
through digital digital
bring us travel opportunities and
aude and marc denault de  comfort of our
living rooms but at the same time it is in the
opportunities for young people to really
come true
with the training which was not
possible before but the face to face
always remains something for
very important human beings also therefore the
British  council
privileges both and we are working
on the axes to keep what is
precious religious that exists in
face to face moments between people
but at the same time we do a lot
more through us digital offer in
dc2 future post break 7 british land
only france
to tell you the truth the bricks site does
not change the fact that the uk has
existed in europe forever and so
we have the stories that we
share together we are on
another chapter we have to build it
we have to rebuild together and I  think
that the bridge as for the swore a very
very very strong and clear role in this
construction there after brick if it gives
us the opportunities  és also
to see differently how to
build our lives and the world together